we've already seen scenarios where we
start with a differential equation and
then we generate a slope field that
describes the solutions to the
differential equation and we use that to
visualize those solutions what i want to
do in this video is do an exercise that
takes us the other way start with the
slope field and figure out which
differential equation is the slope field
describing the solutions for and so i
encourage you to look at each of these
options and think about which of these
differential equations is being
described
by this slope field i encourage you to
pause the video right now and try it on
your own
so i'm assuming you have had a go at it
so let's work through each of them and
the way i'm going to do it is i'm just
going to find some points that seem to
be
easy to do arithmetic with and we'll
we'll see if the if the slope described
by the differential equation at that
point is consistent with the slope
depicted in the slope field
and just for simplicity maybe i'll do x
equals 1 y equals 1 for all of these
so i'm going to see what so when x
equals 1 and y is equal to 1. so this
first differential equation right over
here if x is 1 and y is 1 then d dydx
would be negative one over one or
negative one
d y
d x would be negative one now is that
depicted here when x is equal to one and
y is equal to one our slope isn't
negative one our slope here looks
positive
so we can rule
this one out
now let's try the next one
so if x is equal to 1 and y is equal to
1 well then d y
dx would be equal to 1 minus one or zero
and once again i'm just i just picked
one
x equals one and y equals one for
convenience i could have picked any
other i could pick negative five and
negative seven this just makes the
arithmetic a little easier once again
when you look at that point that we've
already looked at our slope is clearly
not zero we have a positive slope here
so we could rule that out
once again for this magenta differential
equation if x and y are both equal to
one then one minus one is once again
going to be
equal to
zero
and we've already seen the slope is not
zero here so
rule that one out
and now here we have x plus y so when x
is one y is one are the derivative of y
with respect to x is going to be one
plus one which is equal to two
now this looks interesting it looks like
this this slope right over here could be
two this looks like one this looks like
two i'd want to validate some other
points but this looks like a really
really good candidate and you can also
see what's happening here
when d y d x is equal to x plus y you
would expect that as x increases for a
given y your slope would increase and as
y increases for a given x your slope
increases and we see that
if we were to just follow if we were to
hold y constant one but increase x
along this line we see that the slope is
increasing it's getting steeper and if
we were to keep x constant and increase
y across this line we see that the slope
increases and in general we see that the
slope increases as we go to the top
right
and we see that it decreases as we go
to the bottom left and both x and y
become much much more negative so i'm
feeling pretty good about this
especially if we can knock this one out
here if we can knock that one out
so d y i d x is equal to x over y well
then when x equals 1 y equals 1
d y
dx
would be equal to 1.
and this slope looks larger than 1. it
looks like 2 but since we're really just
eyeballing it let's see if we can find
something that more clearly where this
more clearly falls apart so let's look
at the situation when let's look at the
situation when they both equal negative
one
so x equals negative one and y is equal
to negative 1.
well in that case d y d x should still
be equal to 1 because you have negative
1 over 1. do we see that over here so
when x is equal to negative 1
y is equal to negative 1
our derivative here looks
looks negative it looks like negative 2
which is consistent with this yellow
differential equation and the slope here
is definitely not a positive 1.
so we could rule this one out as well
and so we should feel pretty confident
that this is the differential equation
being described and now that we've done
it we can actually think about well okay
what are the solutions for this
differential equation going to look like
well it depends where they start if you
have or what points they contain if you
have a solution
that contains that point it looks like
it might go
looks like it might do something
looks like it might do something like
something
like
this
if you had a solution
that contained i don't know if you had a
solution that contained this point it
might do something
it might do
something
like that
and of course it keeps going it looks
like would asymptote towards y is equal
to negative x this downward sloping this
this this this this essentially is the
line y is equal to negative x actually
no that's not line equals y equals
negative x this is the line y is equal
to negative x
minus 1.
so that's this line right over here and
it looks like if you had
if you if you had you're in a solution
if you had a if the solution contained
say this point right over here you would
actually that would actually be a
solution to the differential equation y
is equal to
y is equal to negative x whoops y is
equal to negative x
minus 1. and you can verify that if y is
minus 1
then the x and negative x cancel out
you're just left with d y d x is equal
to negative 1 which is exactly what's
being described by this slope field
anyway hopefully you found that
interesting